so what was it about the story Wonder
Woman in the character that like drew
you into its two things really it's it's
both very early memory of seeing
Superman and Superman really affecting
and changing my life as a genre that I
that that I believe in but as an
experience that is like that of great
filmmaking great cinema and so from that
moment on I have really believed in in
superhero films and I've seen many great
ways of going about them and then my
personal love for Wonder Woman Lynda
Carter did such an incredible job
bringing her to the screen in the 70s
and I as a child saw that and it ignited
my imagination to be Wonder Woman and so
you I always you know on the playground
every little girl would fight over who
got to be Wonder Woman and you'd be so
excited if you did and in your head that
role play made you everything you ever
wanted to be and also it's like it
educates you about about what it would
be to be a hero which is a great thing
to practice as a practice of youth and
so all these years later when I came to
Hollywood there are many films I want to
make but one of the one of the handful
of movies that I really have always said
oh I would love to make one of those
love to make one of those little obscene
make one of those one of them was a
great superhero origin story and Wonder
Woman still being available to do that
with no one having ever done that before
from the moment that I had any you know
success as a director it was one of the
first things that I said wow that I
can't believe no one's made one a woman
I would love to make that yeah
definitely like comes into my brain I
was watching the film good just like the
Sensibility yeah
interactions because I loved that so you
recently trained a couple of real yeah
what was your impression of seeing some
on screen in that experience very pretty
incredible I love IMAX
I have always loved the IMAX experience
it's so stunning and as much as there
have been a million different forms of
cinema that have been a gimmick at one
point IMAX is kind of special in this
other way where it it somehow has all of
the integrity of a film and and grand
film with an expanded experience rather
than a changed experience you know and
so I loved it the detail and seeing you
know the incredible detail of a film
that thank God I am so proud of how it
was shot because you know Matt Jensen
our cinematographer just nailed it did
this incredible job but then seeing that
come to life on this massive screen was
pretty surreal pretty incredible I would
love to see it in 2d as well but it
looks great in 3d what do you think
audiences what is added to their
experience and they go like man I think
two things one is just purely visual and
aesthetic how incredible to see the
detail that you might not see often and
you know we're talking about a day and
age where people watching in all sorts
of limited ways to see that detail so on
so you know beautifully crystal clear so
the second thing is it is my some of my
favorite imax experiences are immersive
ones where like I recently had seen the
hubble space craft one and it is it's
unbelievable to sit in a theater and
look at the hubble space craft shot in
IMAX and as I stared at it I thought to
myself that's that's exactly what it
would look like that's exactly what it
would look like I can barely see off the
screen and it's got such clarity that
I'm seeing that better than that
astronaut is because I don't have this
on I felt the same way when I saw
Everest and I watched it over and over
again I'm not
in the snow suit you know hypoxic and
exhausted I'm actually at the top of
Everest better than ever and so when you
think about applying that which we're
really only starting to really apply
shooting that way for an entire future
film what an incredible thing to bring
people into an experience where they
truly are there you know I mean the
distance between the viewer and the
screen is always something I'm very
thoughtful of it in because I never want
to put the sound too far behind you
because then it distance you from the
screen which is already far away
vanishes in IMAX you are so close to it
already you know not literally but
you're in that experience so it just
changes the immersive quality of the
story you mentioned I'm shooting an iMac
in the time in the interview that you
did with China you mentioned that you
might be interested in working with IMAX
members in the future yeah I need plans
or is there anything that we can do to
like make that yeah I have no concrete
plans yet but I'm definitely extremely
interested and I will be looking into it
I definitely will I think what interests
me is just purely the the output you
know it's it's I love to shoot on film
and the idea of also adding that much
grain and detail and and - and nuance to
the film would be pretty incredible I
mean other films all digitally I'm sure
but at the moment for the films that I'm
working on I think shooting them in film
is incredible and so you know big or
negative a bigger frame I mean the great
you know photographers still work on
large scale you know negative that
that's that's very attractive are there
things in particular that you think are
going to be that will stand out
especially in iMac I think I think it is
really the emotional action scenes you
know I think that that they will all
many things will look great but to be so
close to an emotional action moment
where you're really experiencing that
hopefully through Wonder Woman's shoes
will
increased yeah I think you don't realize
how powerful it can be to see a person
space like that big yeah for that like
I'm acting really lend itself to sort of
that yeah as well as like a big scope
sort of shot yeah so believe it or not
you were actually our first female
narrative film director amazing doesn't
have an I'm actually being exhibited in
theaters Wow Wow we want to recognize
that of course there what does that mean
to you it's an honor I feel so lucky to
be the one I'm also surprised every time
something like that comes up I'm like
wow you know I feel you know struck by
the significance and that and that
there's obviously something needs to
change and when that's true but I'm so
happy that I'm getting my film shown and
the support yeah I mean we're super
excited about it of course an abdomen in
Hollywood what does it mean to work on a
superhero's on such a huge profit
well I think it's great because my
favorite thing about comics and
superheroes if it has actually always
been great diversity of type represented
there's just as there's not the need for
one superhero there's many many kinds of
superheroes um you know it's great to
have first of all she's just an iconic
she's one of the grand-am the biggest of
the big superheroes so first of all
that's incredible but also incredible to
have a different superhero
then people are used to in the fact that
she's a woman you know show the mettle
of like the grandiosity of all these
superheroes yeah there's something very
different about this film compared to
maybe some of the other two people but
just comparing to the acceptability can
you talk a little bit like the tone of
the balance yeah so different like yeah
yeah my intention was to make a great
film that is emotional and big and
classic and that has been done before
but it has not been the vogue recently
for for what people are going for in
superhero films so I was excited to try
to bring that that gold back and and
then of course I am interested in
emotions in film above all and so I
think the thing that I aspire to do is
make make someone experience story you
know in an intimate way
you know in a first-hand way and and
that fascinates me whether I can put you
in the shoes of a serial killer or
whether I can make you think you're a
superhero like that's a wonderful
extinct if I could bring that to people
and then and then I can not only be
telling a story and hopefully
entertaining you but also I can maybe be
bringing a understanding into or you're
one part of all kinds of decision-making
processes so so that's probably a unique
objective you know just as there have
been many unique objectives put into the
into the medium awesome cool yeah thank
you
you